so far we've looked at primitive
recursion things where you can use
recursion if you want to but you don't
have to because it can be dearie cursed
and turned into an iterative four loop
and we did factorial and we did
Fibonacci both of which are primitive
recursive in this sense and there would
be a great danger in thinking well
surely you can do anything then in for
loops why bother with the recursion at
all well there are some things which are
so fundamentally recursive that you just
have to do them recursively it became
clear to mathematicians really at the
turn of the last century about the
nature of functions in general that
there were some things that were so if
you like huge so enormous so badly
behaved that they just had to be
recursively defined and I think one of
the earliest people to realize this was
a research student of David Hilbert's
now who is David Hilbert we're back on
numberphile territory again probably
perhaps the greatest mathematician of
the late 19th and early 20th century it
was phenomenal mathematical genius
capabilities and so on he was at getting
an in Germany and I think I'm right in
saying that Ackerman was one of his
research students and it's film
Ackerman's function that we're going to
look at today the test was can you come
up with something that just has to be
done totally recursively you can't do it
as it were in a for loop even those
those haven't been properly invented at
that stage what became clear as a result
of work started by Ackerman and by
others is that we've got a hierarchy of
program types right down at the bottom
the simple ones we've seen the ones that
can be dear accursed these are primitive
recursive there's a whole layer on top
of that where they're functions where
you just have to define them recursively
just above this set are the recursively
enumerable functions let's be clear here
by saying primitive recursive at the
bottom I'm including every other program
that isn't recursive and regarding a
thing that just goes through a sequence
as being a very simple example of a
primitive recursive program with no real
recursion in it and anything that's got
four loops or nested for-loops
well actually you could have done that
recursively and probably languages like
Haskell do for all I know but they still
count as a simplest form of program
primitive recursion if it's got
recursion in there at all you could
always do recurse it make it into four
loops this next thing recursive on top
of that there's a even more
problematical set of programs above that
which says they're recursive but for
some values of the arguments you put
into the function they will stop and
give an answer and for others they will
go on forever and they will never ever
stop do we how do you define for
everything forever and ever and ever
they will go into just repeating the
same old stack frames and you may not be
aware of it and just go round and round
in and then you'll say but how can I
decide ahead of time for given arguments
whether it will stop or won't and the
answer is
hello Alan Turing in general that may
well be undecidable so above here out in
hyperspace is the great undecidable
universe there are some problems you can
set in computing that just are not
decidable at all not by any algorithm
and one of the great names in this was
curt girdle in the early 1930s and the
second great name for computer
scientists that linked girdles work with
how computer programs worked and with
his Turing machines was Alan Turing he
wrote a famous paper in 1936 about his
Turing machines referred back to Kerr
girdles work and basically said there
are some things in computing that are
undecidable but for the moment we're
coming in here at the next level above
primitive recursive and take a look at
recursive function where I can reason
through with you that it will give an
answer it's not in the nasty set above
it the recursively enumerable x' where
sometimes it would go wrong and just end
up spinning and not doing anything
useful this thing and this is a good
introduction as well to the way that
theoretical computer scientists of which
I am not one but I'll try to give you
the flavor but how you can reason about
programs and how they behave even
without actually executing them the
version of atamans function that tends
to be used nowadays is the one modified
by Peter and by Robinson here is where
all the hard work occurs this is the
recursive function itself will declare
AK for short a function with two
incoming integer arguments and here look
it delivers back an integer result it
delivers back the integer result in its
local variable for two declares for
itself for holding the answer and
eventually of course look it's going to
return the answer but how does it do its
recursive horrors if the incoming
argument m is zero then deliver back the
integer answer n plus one so if i came
in with a common zero two because the M
is 0 it would deliver back to +1 three
easy otherwise if that isn't true if M
isn't 0 if it's any other integer else
if n is zero then the answer is what you
get by calling up acumen recursively
again but this time by reducing the
first argument by one call up a common
with n minus 1 or M and with the first
argument 1 otherwise now that's bad
enough the here comes the real killer if
Emma isn't 0 and if n isn't 0 what's the
general case the general case is that
the answer is a common of M minus 1
notice you're reducing m again look and
this is where a headache starts to set
in this Lozier brain makes you realize
why you can't de returns this into
iteration the second argument for that
generalized call of ackerman is itself a
call of a
come on so you have to go through
endless thousands of stack frames to
calculate just what the second argument
must be to another call of a common it's
going to go through the same agony all
over again now I think you can mentally
visualize just what a huge amount of
computation might be involved here and
how big the numbers might get to be but
what I would like to just draw your
attention to because this is important
is that every time m and n are altered
in going around recursively they reduce
we found out that on the second line it
says if n was 0 and he called up a thing
with a command of n minus 1 in it yeah
so you're reducing M at that place and
even in the horrible worst case the
third line you reduce the first argument
to n minus 1 and within that vile second
argument is Hackman of M n minus 1 so as
you go around this if m and n change at
all they are reduced therefore if your
first two traps which we've got here are
for when M gets down to 0 and when n
gets down to 0 then in the end it will
terminate so long as you feed in
positive integers for m and n now as
ever I have done no error checking
whatever that's down to you I want you
to concentrate on this yeah if you put
negative in numbers in there boy are you
in for a rougher ride yeah it's got to
be positive integers zeros are fine
there must be zero or positive integers
although this is a huge recursive mess
with millions of stack frames
nonetheless by reasoning and saying that
when these values are altered they
always alter downwards you can convince
yourself that this will eventually
deliver an answer now the only trouble
is that in delivering an answer there
may be a huge amount of computation
involved
particularly when we get onto this third
line and you have to run a Cummins
function in order to work out what an
argument to a Commons function is going
to be and just to show you how bad this
gets I've set up two nested for-loops on
I and J taking I from 0 through to 5
actually because it's higher less than 6
J from 0 through to 5 and I call it the
Ackermann function as the arguments be
printed in the standard piece of text
here so you'll get things like acumen 0
0 is whatever and you call the back
ermine recursively to work it out
how's that going for you how is that
going for me well what Steve and I dr.
heartbleed as we now call him we set
this going for weeks ago nearly now the
first few have vanished off the top
you'll be delighted to know that acumen
of 0 3 is valuable for that Ackerman of
2 2 is 7 a kamila 3 2 is 29 doesn't look
too bad now it did have a bit of a
Gasper air between 4 0 which is 13 and
it finally decided that Ackerman for one
was sixty five thousand five hundred and
thirty three it still took it
recursively on this machine three
minutes to work out that Ackerman for
one was 65 533 so this is progress
because this of course is a fairly
modern quad-core pentium or whatever it
is running Linux the previous machine I
had when I first tried this about seven
or eight years ago was a venerable Sun
SPARC blade and the smart blade miracle
of its age took 20 minutes to work that
out so 20 minutes 3 minutes we're
progressing and then do you know I was
looking at this with Steve we've set the
thing going it's still running and I
said oh you know it probably won't be
there
and it'll be if it took three minutes to
work out something whose answer was 65
533 it'll take about maybe sixty-five
thousand times three minutes to work the
next one out and did a few calculations
yeah about four months on this machine
something like that no I've just looked
into it more deeply and reminded myself
of the appalling properties of the
acumen function when it starts to build
no it will take two ^ 65536
it will take 3 times 2 to the 65535
imaginably huge it's no good saying it's
astronomical it's way beyond
astronomical the number of particles I
think including all Dark Matter isn't
more than about 2 to the 300 something
like that the number of seconds since
the Big Bang is probably about 2 to the
500 or 600 at most not 2 ^ 65535 65535
ever flow isn't signaled to us you know
integer numbers sometimes tend to roll
over the top of go negative so who knows
what will happen I'll probably stop this
off now when we made this video because
friendly I have not I don't think I'm
going to survive for 2 ^ 65,536 x 3 for
this to come to an end
I think the astronomers will probably
say the Big Crunch when the universal
gets down to a dot again even that is
probably gonna happen in about another 2
to the power few hundred this sort of
behavior is often called super
exponential one of the ways of
indicating that a function probably has
to be done recursively and can't be done
in for loops is when it starts behaving
super exponentially not just like n to
the power n which will be exponential
but
n ^ n ^ n ^ n to the power of n done n
times and your brain just collapses and
refuses to even contemplate what that
means
in fact I've noticed one commenter thank
you whoever it was when somebody said
surely you can do anything in four loops
what do you have to do solely
recursively somebody's picked up I think
one of those numbers I don't know much
about really big ones called Google's
and Google plexes but they've been
covered in numberphile and said how
about acumen of G 64 I think it's called
how about a comment of G 64 G suit of
all the arguments before you ever start
inflating them are still absolutely
astronomical but the really interesting
thing is that although we can never know
what the answer is and the answer to -
to the 65,000 whatever divided by three
that is going to involve twenty thousand
decimal digits when it finally comes out
way beyond the Big Crunch but by
reasoning with the program in the way we
did we know it is not uncomputable think
back to the original hierarchy because
we can never know the answer to some of
these values does it mean it's
uncomputable no uncomputable means there
is no algorithm for doing it acumen is a
perfectly good algorithm you can prove
it terminates it's just none of us are
going to be around long enough to find
out what some of those values are
oh I don't know what factorial 3 is it's
three times factorial 2 so I've got to
know what factorial 2 is going so here's
the fan you draw an arc and you end up
with this beautiful looking spiral known
as the Fibonacci spiral